what's up for the folks you see this on
YouTube as soon as it starts oh man
I'm putting juice on here oh noes no
favor friendly what's up guys what's up
YouTube's like oh the only people who
watch youtuber twelve-year-olds we have
to treat them that way
no the 12 year olds of today are the 22
year olds of yesterday it's crazy how
fast people grow what's up guys what's
up everybody got my phone back
well actually know how to get a new
phone but it doesn't matter I got the
red the the product red edition of the
iPhone 7 which I'm really kind of diggin
you think Watchmen are part of yeah
definitely think Watchmen are part of
rebirth um never thought about doing
down in my comics but I definitely think
that the Watchmen are gonna be part of
GC rebirth and it's it'll be cool to see
them like I love when we get like the
Watchmen vs. the Justice League I think
that would be pretty solid but you know
I didn't watch the NFL Draft I'm not an
NFL draft kind of guy not really my
thing but um vapenation it needs that 1
million not going to do that but what's
my favorite worst superhero definitely
Bailey Hoskins Bailey Hoskins is the
worst superhero my videos rock I
appreciate it um more aliens comics for
the wind yeah this coming week is all
going to be guardians of the galaxy
stuff but then next week we go back to
our regular schedule so that's usually
what I do like whenever like a major
movie comes out or something like that
like all my regular stuff just gets put
on put on hold you know just for the
week cuz you know why would I do aliens
when guardians of the galaxy is coming
out you know that's kind of that's kind
of a weird situation to take but um
opinions on Multiversity I liked
Multiversity I thought it was a pretty
cool story so leave some likes by the
way guys I want to see some tons some
thumbs up
when we see it likes peeps am I going to
be the button yes I'm definitely gonna
do the button um Rob Yuma dude I
appreciate it but what I'm thinking
about doing is wait until we get about
two weeks under the button like next
week just start going through all the
individual comics like I think I might
do that just do them individually
because it's for issues and it spanned
over four weeks so it's one issue a week
but how do I read this as best I can
um what's my favorite flash definitely
Barry Allen I think Barry Allen stuff
was my favorite one
let's see please explain your idea of
how to end secret Empire of if it hadn't
already been done like if it hadn't had
done before I would have killed Captain
America I wouldn't kill them off but you
can't really do that
you can't do that gag you got to redo it
again so the button got delayed no it
didn't the button didn't get delayed
let's see the button delayed let's see
Oh
damnit flash number 22 got delayed well
it's a good thing that we're not doing
it right off the bat then well well I
was pushed back a week damn that sucks
well that's not good oh oh well um
that's that that kind of sucks but
that's par for the course it's just the
way it works so well I do more Ultron
stories uh yeah probably I mean Ultron
does a problem very often though so yeah
I don't wouldn't really see a reason but
Rob what am I going to do Ultimates to
actually on the schedule I have when do
I have Ultimates two scheduled I thought
I recorded Ultimates - did I thought I
recorded it I have it on my desktop
let's see uh let's sort by yes I have
Ultimates - Volume one recorded that one
can probably go up what time is it now
at seven o'clock showw I'm going to say
I could go out this weekend could go up
now but it's too it's too late for that
we'll do that one next Thursday we'll do
alternates - Volume one there we go
all right now it's later I knew I
recorded it because it basically goes
through it redoes the origin of the
universe but I was like surely I
recorded Ultimates - ok well at school
because none of means we have videos
recorded phone actually or a video
recorder for next week which by the way
this week were like I said we're leaving
out like superior spider-man we're doing
we're doing guardians of the galaxy
volume 1 which is when Ironman joins a
team and we're doing a Angela for the
people kept asking about like Angela
have like Thor's sister ended up in the
Marvel Universe Angela from spawn we're
going to cover that that comes out
tomorrow and then we're doing guardians
of the galaxy disassembled and then I'm
debating on doing blackboard X black
vortex is okay I didn't really care for
black vortex too much but maybe we'll do
black vortex and then we're going to do
how to kill guardians of the galaxy then
we're going to do the story where a
group fought Hulk which is an amazing
story and
then we're going to do the whole planet
Symbian and all I kind of stuff through
the looking-glass all the way up to like
the modern-day guardians of the galaxy
so was literally all guardians of the
galaxy stuff this week so with a few
kind of weird stories peppered in but
yes I have read the injustice to comics
and I definitely dig the injustice to
countries no I'm not gay anybody who
knows me knows that like my my celebrity
crush is most definitely Candice Patton
I'm Mac Anna's madam she's a beautiful
woman I can't believe I just said that
on YouTube um anyway am I going to do
any more Walking Dead anytime soon I'm
waiting for the current story doc to
finish we go the thing that just wrapped
up but I mean I'll probably do it when
the show comes back to the honest just
because of the fact that it's just like
Candice Patton is the one who plays iris
West on the flash she's a beautiful
woman
ah let's see yo dog you look like my
brother okay if you guys are going to
troll me and you want your comments to
get to the top when you're trolling me
then you super chat because then all
then like I'll see your troll comments
more than I'm seeing them right now
which isn't very often so um let's see
do I like Bucky I think Bucky's a great
character I think Thunderbolts is kind
of weird
I think Thunderbolts have just kind of
been floating around hasn't really been
doing a whole lot but you know I kind of
dig Bucky so um yeah I feel like
everybody has a crush on Candice Patton
[Laughter]
man I need to be in the MCU I wish like
I wish I would be in the MCU that would
be awesome am I going to the midnight
showing of guardians yes and going to
the midnight showing or guardians of the
galaxy I'm going Thursday and my sister
and I are going on Friday but I'm taking
my editor with me on Thursday so that's
going to be that's gonna be pretty cool
so um if Barry dies does the Speed Force
dawn not to my knowledge I don't think
that's the case I think it's just he
created the Speed Force and it's just
there now like you really can't stop it
so um does Peter called out powers in
the comics no Peter quill does not have
powers in the comics I feel like this is
going to turn into a Q&A about guardians
of the galaxy so that's fine if you guys
want to do that I'll have any problem
with that but yeah I figured it's
already out in the in the
okay let's see uh did I say I would
cover what I didn't catch that last part
in my Power Rangers fan yes I grew up
watching The Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers as far as I'm concerned the
original Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
are like the only good ones but you know
still I know a lot of people love the
modern-day Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
so yeah this this chat is going crazy
how long before another Rick and Morty
again that'll be next week when we get
back to our regular stuff so I guess I
probably should put Rick and Morty down
there but we have when we missed out
value in comics last week then we're not
doing it this week just because of the
fact that it's you know got into the
galaxy so we're going to do we're going
to do another aliens we'll do aliens
aliens vol 2 will do the nightmare
asylum nightmare Asylum is cool that's
where the alien outbreak happens on
earth it's really really cool it's a
really cool story so um my man that's
Rob going live now I'm your son well
that's going to weird I didn't know that
but living tribunal versus Lucifer
Morningstar and when you're talking
about levels of power that are just
insane I mean honestly I don't I feel
like in justice did the best job of
having like people with insane reality
weapon powers facing off because like
like Trigon and mr. mixup it like one
against each other and it basically
rendered reality asunder they basically
decided to kind of send them off to like
nothingness in order to save things so
honestly at that point you're just
talking about power that's so extreme
that some things spiraling out of
control what's my favorite Batman comic
uh I'm like I'll do anything on the
signal Nimrod unless he comes back then
it would be cool
um my favorite Batman comic is probably
quarter bowels I think that's the
coolest thing because it introduces the
idea that there's our group operating
out of Gotham that Batman never knew
about and that right there is just
downright crazy so that was that's kind
of interesting
let's see one more I finish infinity war
uh next week or next year all right you
guys want you guys want to hear
something cool you guys want to see
something cool hopefully you guys don't
run off when I tell you this but check
aside okay so so we have we have Spider
Man going right we have spider-man um
and spider-man is slated to run unto oh
should I delete it all those by accident
that one's going to run until at least
like August roughly maybe a little bit
less but it'll basically run the month
of the movie and then we should be done
shortly after that like within a week of
July whether it's the end or you know
the beginning of August I don't member
off top my head but anyway then we get
into Thor and we do all the all the Thor
stuff so Thor is going to be a pretty
lengthy series Thor well that was not
going to be super long that was gonna be
about as long as spider-man but the
Thanos whole thing is all we're going to
do is we're going to start with the
origin of Thanos and then we're going to
run all the way up until the modern day
which I need to add in a couple things
in there but we're doing the origin of
Thanos and then the whole cosmic cube
storyline so that's like when he first
fights when he first appears he fights
iron man when he tries to get the Cosmic
Cube and then we'll do like Thanos quest
and then infinity golem we're going to
redo all Infinity Gauntlet and then the
aftermath what flavor is my fate o
stranger x9 what flavor is my fav also
have you ever seen JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure it's so dope Thank You
stranger x9 for five bucks I've never
seen JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and I
don't know that I want to because I
heard is really weird and the flavor of
my vape is called nightshift by Bell
McCloud Weber so let's see uh what in
the world okay there we go for some
reason it wasn't loading up all the way
it was kind of weird it was holding on
anyway so we're doing all that stuff
then we're doing Infinity Gauntlet
infinity war infinity crusade cosmic
powers with a nose just like fights
everybody in the cosmos war of kings and
I Alicia conquests realm of kings I mean
all that stuff going all the way to
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers so
we're covering a lot of stuff that is
going to be about 80 weeks
91 weeks worth of stuff although we can
leave out Fantastic Four we don't need
to read
Fantastic Four but we do need to cover
doom or maybe possibly I don't know we
could probably leave out Dillmore now
that I think about it let's see Benny
hit me up he's like hey man you got
$20,000 that's money in a dresser drawer
right and it was I was like really man
who's over here never you're hitting me
up with all right uh Vinny's harassing
me anyway okay so back to your all's
questions that's all right
I've never a 2000ad so Final Crisis I'm
probably not gonna do final crisis final
classes is crazy what about infinity war
yes infinity war is next year
well I ever do read daughter of Krypton
are you talking about the one where
we're a super girl becomes a Red Lantern
Vinny that's my phone and LA is that the
one you're talking about where she
becomes a Red Lantern maybe I'm not
really sure I mean that's really more of
like a Supergirl storyline than anything
else
so Jared Bagley how relevant is quasar
and century to the current Marvel story
arcs not relevant at all quasar century
are virtually non-existent in the
current marvel line of stories which is
kind of disappointing the only thing
we've seen about the century in Marvel
Comics recently has been when he was in
contest of Champions and that was it and
then yeah that was that was about it
and then quasar plays ours there but
it's like a new version of quasar and we
have no idea what's going to go on with
her character so I have no clue she's
just kind of there I mean really I think
the days of like the Marvel cosmology
we're kind of at their height during
like annihilation mileage a conquest
Thanos imperative guardians of the
galaxy that kind of stuff I think about
the days of Marvel's cosmology being
insane or kind of you know kind of gone
now so um what rings his house wouldn't
warren i think he's won them all let's
see
origin of Groot um we should probably do
that I mean Groot does have an
origen I'm pretty sure I mean it's a
backup feature but he does have you know
he does have an origin so uh I don't
know maybe um isn't the collector
important in the MCU
I haven't live and I'd done a video on
him because all he's done is just
collected some he hasn't played like a
major role yet there is grandmaster
though which I might do in origin does
Grandmaster have an origin let's see
Marvell I don't think Grandmaster has
like an origin per se I don't think any
of the guardians of the universe or
guardians of the galaxy I don't think
any of the elders of the universe have
origins I think he was just there one
day so uh yeah I want to do more Walking
Dead comics when the show comes back
let's see what ever explained manga
probably not uh Damien no any
expectation or hopes for Batman metal um
I don't know I mean I don't know a whole
lot about it uh I mean I know it's there
and I know that they were telling me
about it on the podcast I know it's
supposed to be like supposed to be like
a like a its own imprint I think Batman
metal if Scott Snyder and Greg Capullo
are being given their own imprint for
about man I think one of the biggest
issues with all-star Batman is this felt
so far removed from everything that's
going on which is kind of good and kind
of bad I mean it's good because it's
basically self-contained but it's kind
of bad because you feel so isolated from
like all the crazy stuff that's leading
up to like the reveal of the Watchmen so
that's kind of an issue but I don't I
don't know I mean okay I'll read it I
mean I think it'll be kind of cool
because their work on
you know watching will call their work
on on Batman during the new 52 is
absolutely insane Wow
Trevor done 20 bucks thank you hey Rob I
love your channel think you can cover
more spawn I also want a Rob core ring
there's so many indie comics that I'm
covering at the moment I don't know I
mean spawns kind of an ongoing series so
maybe once we're done like we all know
forever really be done covering valiant
but I mean we might be able to do it
somewhere along lon maybe I'll just kind
of pepper and spawn stories every once
in a while I'm not a hundred percent
sure but a Rob core ring is something
that we're actually building up to we're
building up to the release of a Rob port
ring and the ultimate recap series so if
you guys don't know about ultimate recap
myself Benny Caitlin and well I guess
Dylan the back end he's the editor we're
doing this ongoing story and I think
Sal's a ninja now - we're doing this
ongoing story where we basically have me
leading up to getting a Rob core ring so
that's going to be kind of fun I think
it'll be pretty interesting but uh but
yeah um x-men legacy quest trilogy uh I
don't think I have a read that so how to
kill dr. Manhattan that will come out
probably when dr. Manhattan makes his
first official appearance in in DC
Comics
so um am i watching somewhere I Jack I
was but I kind of lost interest in it
hey Rob Oh Jonathan Gibson hey well that
sounds like an American named Jonathan
Gibson that's cool hey Rob fan from the
fan from the UK since my Civil War two
videos what were Civil War videos holy
cow you've been here a long time are you
still working out like a champ and can
you teleport through the shield and
secret Empire I have yeah I've got my
terminal over there and I've got my gym
set in the bedroom um yeah I mean I
guess but I'm not working out as hard as
I should but as far as I know you cannot
teleport through the shield but that is
a question to ask because right now the
shield just popped up so we don't really
know the full extent of its strengths
and weaknesses I'm sure that that you
know it'll be addressed by it'll be
addressed by Nick Spencer but right now
I don't think there's anybody stuck out
of the shield who can teleport
everybody's sucking everybody who can
teleport is inside the shield so uh
Jared Bagley
have you read the prototype comment
by Dark Horse also why did marbles table
antivenom Marvel sobbed anti-venom to
make the way for agent venom because
they were just kind of progressing
through the the venom character so I
don't know and and what was the other
question uh oh no no I have a red
prototype I don't even heard of
prototypes but I guess maybe I should
check it out is it based on the game
basically the prototype game because I
never played those games either
um link one two three a love your
channel
most of my subscribed channels are
hurting due to youtube boycott has it
affected you not really
the YouTube ad boycott isn't really
doing anything to me it's not
significant in a any major way at least
not for me anyway
Paulo Andre Arashi ODS
just 220 bucks aren't I appreciate it
man I appreciate it Paula you didn't say
anything but yeah I mean you know I love
you meant to say something alright a
couple I want to get to make sure I'm
answering questions for some you guys
who aren't using super chat I don't want
to I don't you to feel left out do I
think Bruce Banner will come back and
secret Empire no but I think I'll come
back in generations I think that will
definitely happen how do you feel about
the Titans live-action show and Geoff
Johns being a writer and maybe an
executive producer I have full faith in
Geoff Johns um the fact that he's going
to be a writer I think is going to make
the show all the better the question
comes into play in terms of how much
they're going to follow his script it's
one thing for him to write it it's
another for somebody to come along and
just edit the hell out of it so it
doesn't look like anything he originally
wrote so I have I have no idea
well America Chavez is outside the
shield and she should be able to get
back in that would that be the question
or does it block any use of magic like
does it block the ability for anybody to
create portals inside the earth because
that would be the question I asked I
mean there's one thing for her to be
able to make portals is another for her
to be able to make portals in Earth so
that is a question that that I don't
know Mario when are you doing a video on
the button storyline we need your view
on it please talk about it now the
button storyline will come out when it
finishes especially because it's
apparently been delayed so it's only for
issues so I mean we have you know four
or five weeks and it will be anything
through terrible but that works out
winter done it in two bucks thank you
favorite guardians of the galaxy
character Groot
I love Gertz character I am Groot like
it's just funny because it's like he
says it in like totally in like
inappropriate places like things where
you would expect an in-depth
conversation he's just like I am Groot
but like somehow rocket racoon always
understands him and it's just kind of
funny to me this is one of those funny
things but hey Rob would you ever write
your own comic I've thought about it
before if I were going to write a comic
I'd want to write a Batman comic to be
honest but I thought about it I thought
about writing like an original graphic
novel where Batman gets the Blue Lantern
ring that I think would be kind of cool
what's the best thing to come out of DC
rebirth everything is the best thing to
come out of easy rebirth I think Action
Comics is probably the best but someone
has your phone and it's posting on
Twitter not always messing around with
you guys that's that's me above god
everything is all copacetic it's cool
I wanted me a next venture talk about I
just really just showered him in phrase
about how awesome I thought his writing
was I was just like dude you've got some
of the best like I think people are
going to say is this some of the best
Captain America work in a long time like
I definitely dig what's going on um
let's see am I going to do ruin King
Thor yes we're going to cover that once
we go through our stuff that's really
part of Ragnarok more than anything else
and it's only for like two pages that it
happens so there's not like a whole
gravy huge in-depth thing about rune
King Thor but anyway uh how come I
didn't cover Game comics like Mortal
Kombat characters never really had an
interest in doing mortal combat comics
it just wasn't really my thing it just
never really got into it so I never
really saw a reason to cover it let's
see do you think you can cover all of
the watchman's stuff in time well that's
what I'm kind of debating honest is one
how's the button going to turn out if
the button is going to turn out that
it's basically just like hey you know
the Watchmen are there then we'll do
some watchman stuff if it's just the
button and it's just like you know like
they call themselves the Watchmen then
you know then maybe you know I don't
know I mean we will it's just what they
do at the end of the button will
determine how fast I cover Watchmen
stuff I'm going to truth we can cover
like the all 12 issues of the Watchmen
in two videos we can do that in one day
you know it's just a matter of when I'm
going to do that so can I do a kyle
rayner video well I thought about that
when I was going through Geoff Johns
Green Lantern I thought about doing
like a kyle rayner video but i kind of
felt like with what he did with like ion
the torchbearer and like ion the dying
flame or whatever it is I kind of
figured like that's really all we need
with kyle rayner so um I kind of you
know named a title this should be it's
just now I'm not going to do that but
now I kind of figure that's that's like
all the stuff that we would talk about
with Kyle Rayner that matters it's all
covered in Jeff Jones run so I figured
if we're going to do Jeff Jones run
anyway then we might as well just a
little it'll cover all the collimator
stuff so um what would be my dream
crossover event the Justice League vs
The Watchmen that would be my dream
crossover event now or like dr.
Manhattan goes awry and it's like the
Justice League team up with the Watchmen
to take out dr. Manhattan I mean that I
think would be kind of cool but um let's
see new injustice India new injustice
videos we're waiting for the story to
finish before we jump or waiting for
like the first arc to finish before we
jump into injustice
do I like Red Hood yes I love Red Hood
have I read the all new spider-man run
yes I assume you're talking about only
wonderful Marvel yes I've read worldwide
and like dead no more cloak conspiracy
all that kind of stuff so let's see
origin of how we're not origin of our
girls breasts we're not doing that can
shadow oh this comes from the spider
works can shadow get Wolverine
out of the adamantium statue or can
Shadowcat get wolverine ahead of the
adamantium statue
um maybe I don't know the only issue
with her doing that is historically
speaking the shadow cat if she if she
want to reach in and grab him
she can't grab objects while she's
tangible while she's intangible and if
she makes herself tangible she'll have
her hand cut off so just because of the
fact that it'll basically she'll become
tangible and the adamantium will just
cut right through her so um I don't see
how that's a possibility I'm pretty sure
has a reason why it hasn't been done so
far so now whether or not Marvel thought
of that I have no idea but that's
probably why it hasn't been
done so far so who is sabotage I think
saboteur is Wally West from the future
I think it's an evil Wally West um let's
see
Rob how did it kill dr. fate episode
please yes we'll probably do that is
some more long line just for the sake of
it so am i hiring interns no I'm not
hiring interns the origin of Adam
warlock I thought we had that did we
have a video on the origin of Adam
warlock I feel like that was a video
that we made I thought it was one that I
recorded
that's injustice origins maybe it's one
that I recorded but didn't do anything
with yeah I don't know I think I
recorded it I didn't do anything with it
which means that I still have it on my
computer but you know um let's see will
you do I DW teenage meet Ninja Turtles
um maybe I'm not really sure I never
really got into the new Turtles comics
so never really had a reason to read it
let's see Constantine versus dr. strange
dr. strange
he's just wildly powerful I think is
beyond anything Constantine can do dr.
strange couldn't work reality I'm pretty
sure Constantine can't do that so let's
see ah let's there we go
what am I going to do at fit anymore
part two next year when we do our cosmic
stories let's see ah what is you had
known or comics of him for background
what like I don't my videos somebody's
like your videos of the share I
[Laughter]
appreciate that I appreciate that
comment oh man um what I want to see in
original sin movie I would but I feel
like killing the watchers not really
impactful it really was even impactful
it was more or less just like I wonder
who killed him me and that was it I mean
I don't really care about any of the
other subplots I gotta care about the
kingdom of midas coming back or anything
he did not me but um yeah no I don't
think it'd be impactful enough because
we don't really know much about him and
haven't seen enough of him yet so yeah I
read the first arc of the new Punisher
series and I couldn't really get into it
so I didn't really you know I don't
really dig it too much um let's see uh
like walking dad walking dad walk uh
let's see I have no idea why the body's
writing in caps um let's see uh the orb
I didn't care about the core but that
was the weirdest review when it turned
out the orb was behind it all I was like
but why though like are you just going
for like shock value like I don't
understand why the most disappointing
thing coming out of all-new
all-different marvel and DC rebirth I
think the most disappointing thing
coming out of only water for Marvel was
my mask and star brain but I think was
disappointing because nobody was reading
it because it literally covered all the
Marvel cosmic stuff and all you saw
people asking was like what happened to
infinity Wars Galactus where's this
where's that what are the Celestials
doing what's going on with the cosmic
entities they're like night masks of
star Brad answered all that but nobody
was reading it so it was like well I
mean you know they should go read it if
they want the answers or questions
but um let's see
well I cover the latest Doctor Strange
um yeah but there's a lot of more
important things to cover besides that
there's other more important things
besides that so yeah I've seen death
battle nine hundred thousand subscribers
yeah we're almost at a million like
we're like twenty thousand away from a
million
I'm really excited like I'm pretty hyped
God willing we'll be at a million by the
end of June so hopefully fingers crossed
hopefully we cross that line it'll be
exciting if we do so uh when will you
watch Young Justice um I have no idea
I'm watching agent of shield right now
I'm getting caught up and it's really
good like it's pretty amazing
Chris el who's my favorite DC and Marvel
character favorite DC character Superman
I mean just because of the legacy he
created what he stands for I know it
seems kind of kind of kind of you know
like you know I don't know I keep
thinking the word I'm thinking of it
sound it's like stereotype but it's not
um anyway uh you know it's it's I like
Superman is the one that I dig the most
the one in DC anyway in terms of Marvel
probably my favorite character right now
is old man Logan definitely yeah I think
it's definitely old man Logan so uh
somebody call me so I wish a there we go
it seems cliché that's Dylan M turf ah
no too fond of they came up with cliche
Thank You Dylan Lord karna ask the
question any chance of low blows stories
in the future glad to see him showing up
in your content um probably Justice
League of America
I feel like level stores are kind of
interesting but they're a little extreme
and a little over-the-top and it was
always kind of like I'm not I'm not
related to Neil deGrasse Tyson I wish I
was though but they're a little over the
top for me and I could never really get
into them so it's not really my thing
but it's still kind of cool yeah do I
think the Fantastic Four will be
introduced in the MCU I don't think
that's going to happen I don't think
they're going to get the Fantastic Four
Foxx is just going to keep making
terrible movies so hopefully people will
just stop watching them hopefully Fox
will just lose money every time they
make them and obviously just give the
rights back to Marvel hopefully that
happens later on down the line
God willing that's that's the best we
can do guys let's just not go see Fox's
movies on the Fantastic Four so let's
make that happen guys let's not go see
any more Fox fan as a for movies
although in truth after a fan for stick
I don't think we're really gonna have to
do much to make that happen so thank
goodness a house tour my house isn't
that great I don't know why you guys
would want to see a house tour you guys
want to see a house tumor
I can show you my house if I'm if you
want at least a living replace anyway I
mean I'm wouldn't really show like the
bedroom because the bedrooms kind of a
wreck and you guys will need to see that
anyway but so pump pump if it's true
yeah let's see yes yeah yes please house
to her yes everybody's like yes house to
our okay house to where it is alright
let's take you guys on an adventure all
right come with me my my children my
place is kind of a wreck though so bear
with me for a second let me turn the
whatchamacallit on the lights
alright there we go oh that that fans
off enter my family all right
um let us uh okay
keep in mind my desk is a little bit of
a wreck okay so bear with me here all
right okay so that is my desk where all
my stuff gets recorded that's like a 34
inch monitor right there
and there's a shirt yeah so that's not
anything spectacular
alright and then there's my treadmill
over there there's a case that my
computer came in there is maxi max blood
you say hello max all right max is roll
over and show everybody your dick and
don't you two have max it's a problem
that's the camera where I record all my
things for ultimate recap that is a
Canon a TD and it is it's got a rode
microphone on top look how high these
ceilings like ceilings are huge
there's my sign over there I love that
sign right there
home is where the dog hair sticks to
everything but the dog yep that is 100%
true here's my Star Wars posters
episode 1 and then episode 2 and then
episode 3 and then over there is four
and then five and then six a shroud
savage ass or you am I going to review
the IDW transformers um probably not not
really probably not probably I can do
transformers anyway um so here is all of
us a lamp and then a WWE title belt and
then Alexa what's up okay well I don't
you can hear that at all but anyway
there is some Alexa be quiet um and then
there's some blu-rays right there
which are kind of cool and then there's
the box yeah the universal title is what
that is
here's a Darth Vader mug and that thing
is amazing so anyway um okay so there's
there's a dead-ass plant over there
plants dead as hell ah this is my my
wall my wall of knickknacks alright I
love this thing this is my wall of
knickknacks and I dig this so like Alexa
shut it alright um that is where I got
my Mac Pro of course you got like a
stormtrooper helmet this is the base
system for my my stereo which is
actually down there it's kind of on the
bottom of the thing join the alliance
these are all my cool books and
everything I've read as often as I can
and I read all kinds of things like ben
bernanke that was basically the the 2008
economic crisis is when he was talking
about with that let's see the readers
companion to American history December
1941 talks about d-day a handful of
other things just as what's the right
thing to do Steve Jobs and then there's
a few things up there that box right
there is actually for the Apollo twin by
Universal Audio that thing is nice
that's the interface that I use when I'm
recording my audio um
and then let's see Oh check this out
check this out guys alright check this
out right here this this thing right
here this is the staff and
wand of lucius malfoy like that thing is
amazing then of course there's lucious's
mask and this is a menu from American
whiskey which is a really good whiskey
bar in New York I mean a few more things
there's a few more books here that flag
belong to my dad where we got it for a
for my dad and then you know a few other
things here and there and then instance
thing for like a dragon and then some
more camera stuff this is the pocket
Cinema Blackmagic pocket Cinema with a
50 millimeter lens on it and then my bag
usually goes there my camera bag goes
there
so um anyway and then here is a here's
my boss asked gaming system gaming
computer here check this out check this
out that thing is absolutely nuts like
it's pretty badass in anyway there's all
the other stuff down there so then
there's another computer and then yeah
that's really about it I mean not too
much just a thing so
not too much going over the house to her
not too much going on here it's just
kind of a regular place where I live and
eat and poop and pee oh man
nothing nothing too spectacular too wild
or crazy or anything so um anyway so uh
yeah or order comics are not life say
that's a my nine hundred and seventy
thousand subscribers um let's see Rob do
you want Steve Rogers to truly be a
Hydra or classic I like him is Hydra
Captain America to be honest I love him
as a Hydra agent so I think he's pretty
stellar so uh let's see more dog please
max is the laziest dog ever all she
mocks aren't you max she does amazing is
he so lazy not enough turnaround
acknowledgement he just go sit there
well you know he can just be that way so
um not alone uh Paolo Andre okay cool uh
do you have any comic tattoos what do I
recommend I do not have any comic
tattoos comics Torian is the one to ask
about that he's got like he's got Star
Wars he's got all immersive Justice
League they're little symbols and
everything he's got a ton of stuff David
J do you get into World of Warcraft
World of Warcraft did you ever play the
original game on PC and do you know that
the same guy who created the Hulk also
did orcs and the Warcraft movie I did
not know that um and no I do not play
World of Warcraft
what Warcraft is not my thing not play
destiny and that's really about it I
mean I'll usually play Skyrim if I'm
hanging out on PC but that's really
about it um let's see am I going to
review the death of the new 52 Superman
probably not I don't really see a reason
to at this point to be honest yeah
wouldn't it be kind of cool but I
wouldn't really see a reason to do it
now upload - Rob please I eat it like
they're doing like Call of Duty
the world war 2 so I need to get back
into like into playing call of duty so
yeah like I definitely need to do that
again if you guys were going to troll
make sure you guys use super chat make
sure you guys like if you guys give me
money when you troll then I'll see it
more likely than if I don't so because I
know those trolls in here and I think
they're trying to get my attention but I
have too many fans and too few trolls so
hey Rob thanks for the greatest content
on YouTube who could the Avengers take
on after Thanos and the MCU who's hoping
Marvel getting Doctor Doom back I have
no clue who the Avengers are going to
take on after Doctor Doom and that's my
biggest question is like where do we go
after after infinity war that's that's
my question is what do we do after
infinity war I have no clue um let's see
team tain Malachi I hope I pronounced
that right hey Rob big fan wanted to
know if you'd cover invincible if Robert
Kirkman's other comic and it's pretty
good
well thank you for 5 bucks and I think
Benny's actually getting ready to start
invincible so I don't want to step on
his toes too much um I mean I might do
that you know later on but I'll wait
until because I've got the walking dead
and he largely remained hands off the
walking dead when I was doing it so I'm
not gonna do injustice well or do uh
invincible while he's doing in that I'm
not going to step on his toes
so Jonathan Gibson what's up thank you
for the donation
a humble pad for a humble man love what
you do well I appreciate it man I mean
it's it's kind of a humble pad I guess
nothing too crazy here but you know
pretty basic um let's see have I read
the new Punisher series yes I had all
read the first volume it didn't really
dig it too much so uh the chaos king
versus the void the void chaos kings
just not powerful enough damien no oh
thanks again um better hope poison ivy
doesn't find out about that that's what
enemy of the green yeah she's going to
come in and lose her mind you killed my
babies yes I did poison ivy do you want
to like go check out my bed
that's not creepy at all
oh man uh Wow new watch alert uh Rob
winner am I going to do name with a
submariner um I don't know if I'll ever
cover name with a submariner content um
he was just never really a super
interesting character to me um he was
relatively interesting but not anything
outrageous and so you know I don't I
don't know if I'd ever cover him to be
honest um let's see the wild man
opinions on Dan Slott I like Dan Slott I
like his writing I think he's a pretty a
pretty good spider-man writer I know
that I know that right now a lot of
people are hoping that he will leave and
I think events like cologne conspiracy
do a lot to to forward that sentiment
because nothing really came out of it
like nothing of any really have any real
substance came at her for Peter Parker
um but I think he's a good spider-man
writer I mean I kind of like it
so uh KC Sims what would be the
requirements for being chosen to join
the Rob core strong will sense of hope
etc well thank you for 10 bucks and I
guess really the requirements is just
not be a jerk like it be a reasonable
human being and yeah like also have a
willingness to destroy comics story and
everything that he stands for like it's
really kind of the other thing to know
that you major
you know just willingness to bring
everything that he's built crashing down
around him and that's really about the
only other thing so um let's see uh what
music do I listen to largely EDM but I
listen to other stuff too you know rock
and roll stuff like that um holy cow
David die stirrer Jesus thanks for 75
bucks uh have I read the button
crossover yes I read the first two
issues it's amazing like I know the
reaction is just like man like it is
amazing it's so good it is it is one of
the best crossovers that's going on
right now and I like how DC is keeping
them small DC's keeping the crossovers
are like four issues or so they're not
making them like six or seven or eight
or nine or anything like that I think
the only exception of that was night of
the monster man and that one was born
like five or six issues but anyway ah
let's see if I got a lantern ring which
core would I choose I choose the
Sinestro Corps I just love the idea that
Sinestro Corps it's like a Lantern ring
a lantern
a court based on fear it would be it'd
be pretty intense anyway guys we're
going to wrap this episode up I figured
we just do like a quick Q&A I mean
Saturday 9:00 and I didn't really have
any other videos planned for today so I
figured I'll just kind of jump on here
and talk to you guys for a little bit
and yeah so I don't know I mean you know
when I move to Colorado I'll probably do
like a strictly like a house tour video
once I get all settled in and get
everything built up the way that I want
it to be but yeah thanks for coming out
guys it's like it's been fun talking to
you all like way to do this more often
like once a week or every couple weeks
or something on those lines but um yeah
like it's been pretty cool oh wow
winter damn 20 bucks could you do a hero
group versus here group series like
x-men versus the Illuminati or Avengers
versus Justice League how they would
plan and actually get their fight okay
that's pretty in-depth maybe that would
be like a one-off
or something like that like like
Avengers versus the Justice League maybe
I wait to like the Justice League comes
out and just be like Avengers versus the
Justice League like who would win and
just how about this really drawn-out
battle like who would go against who and
what who what power set would match up
and so on and so forth that would
actually be kind of a cool concept but
anyway guys uh yeah I'm gonna bounce off
here and I will catch you all later
peace